opening gates tomorrow guys opening day
of the baseball season cannot wait it's
so great and batting leadoff guys and
show coverage with the to nine 2019
season is the manager of the Los Angeles
Dodgers Dave Roberts back on the show
how are you skipper hey rich what's
happening how you doing I'm doing great
I'm doing great
before we get to all of that being
obviously the baseball season and and
the Dodgers there's a big huge
conversation in the sports world out of
the NFL about change of instant replay
what's your stance on instant replay
with baseball you know what I think I
actually I'm a fan i I think that you
know the players are speaking for people
obviously I've got a bias of you know on
the field and I just want the call to be
right and I think that there are times
where you know it's on it's kind of
undecided or the call stands but I think
for the most part these guys get it
right with the replay I don't think it
takes much time to stupid thing and for
me I think for the most part like to get
to call right more than thought so I'm a
fan well with baseball obviously when
you're talking whether the balls beatin
someone to the bag or as a ball fair or
foul or over the the wall I mean it is
it's usually a line involved what's
happening when the NFL is a judgment
call would you want to see balls and
strikes replayed David no no IIIi don't
think I would like to see that but I do
think that you know I think that you
know there's been talk about that
electric strike zone and stuff like that
where obviously there's still a place
for the home plate umpire and and I
think for anyone I think that you know
one side the human element I think it's
part of baseball has always been but
again the part of getting it right it is
kind of for me outweighs a little bit
and I will say though is that when
baseball players complain about or want
electric strike zone I think the haters
gonna have a rude awakening because
there's a lot more strikes called it
balls that they think so
so that's gonna be something that's
gonna unfold here I'm sure in the next
year yeah you said so interesting what
do you what do you mean by that you
think an electronic eye might be more
I think will favor more the pitcher yeah
what what do you think that I think that
there's bowls that where the hollow of
the knee right below the kneecap and
above the belt or the kind of where you
take your stance and right below the
armpits or however it's kind of the
verbage of the rulebook I do think at
that low ball that players think is down
is a strike and you know more for me
it's North and South versus East and
West West I think that they're the
pitchers they get a little bit more on
the corners but I think north and south
I think that it would the electric
strike zone I think hitters would feel a
shock that the ball is called strikes
Dave Roberts Dodgers manager here on the
Rich Eisen show what's your favorite
Opening Day memory Dave I think for me
my first one with the Dodgers that was
2002 Dodgers Giants I had lead off that
game Kevin Brown Livan Hernandez Barry
Bonds on the other side we ended up
getting our butts kicked
I think Barry hit two homers that day
but just to kind of be my first opening
day start on the line Dodgers Giants
Phillippe Tallulah's on the other side
Jim Tracy my manager it was pretty
special moment for me yeah what about
what's your first opening day what was
your first one was that in 99 or is that
you or the game was in 99 right and then
by first one I think actually my first
one because I was kind of up and down
for three years and then my first full
year was 2000 2000 my first one in well
yeah Wow
so your first one with the Dodgers was
your first one where you you came out of
spring Charlie had you out there huh
what what is your what is your take
coming into a season after having two
long seasons finished short of the
ultimate goal my cake is it's a new
season and I and I think that there's a
lot of excitement obviously every team
thinks to have a chance for the most
part to win the World Series but I think
that it's been a very productive three
years
for me and with this organization with
this club and obviously we haven't won
it all but I see no reason well we won't
put ourselves in that position again and
get over the hump here this year and the
clubhouse
I mean obviously did you feel you need
to address like it's a new year or
what's your sense of that I called a
manager not a yeah and a coach no for
sure rich I think that's a fair question
but but no I think that with the guys
that we have whether it's claiming JT
Kenley David Freese obviously is one of
my favorites I think the thing is that
it's pretty much understood what we need
to do and I don't let our guys get too
far ahead of the next day the next day's
game and I think that's something that's
really boring but I think that it's
something that works it's a method and a
form of that is not too much to overcome
you know just to try to win that day and
that's what we try to do we did kind of
shuffle the deck a little bit bring in
Russell Martin back you bring in Joe
Kelly AJ Pollock so there's different
guys Corey Seager's back this year so
there's a little bit different but but
the core is still intact and it's it's
gonna be a fun team to watch this your
very challenge it's focus group Dave
Roberts Dodgers manager here in the Rich
Eisen show let's talk about then again
who who is there Clayton Kershaw not
getting the start but he is seemingly on
the mend what can you tell me about his
readiness and when we expect to see him
on the mound this year yeah I would say
as we sit here today I would say Clayton
is a couple weeks away for for pitching
for us on Saturday here we've got a
three inning we call it a simulated game
where he faces hitters that he goes in
the dugout three different times pitches
three innings and so that will continue
to build up for that he's doing really
well
a little bit behind as far as he made so
many consecutive opening day starts but
understanding that it's a long season
and we just need him healthy so he's
coming back he'll be fine and Rich Hill
is alongside him on the they call it the
injured list now yes they do
the injure list I want to get my wording
right and he's uh probably a few days
ahead of Clayton so we get these guys
come back soon and Bueller win amount of
Walker and Walker is gonna start the
fourth day of the season but Sunday
against the Diamondbacks and he's raring
to go you're gonna see 97 to 99 on that
Sunday and he's locked and loaded okay
now when you simulate a game are you you
doing just now the two minutes between
innings now I mean you know those rules
they slice to yourself that's fair so
it's kind of try to simulate
the other side officer side so you know
whether it's a five seven ten minute
inning and then we get them back out
there but I hear you know I don't you
just want to make sure you're complying
you know pace of replicate as much as we
can we we call that simulated pace of
play rules I might be the only one to
call in that I might have been the Royal
way what is it like having a shortstop
coming back from Tommy John's surgery
with Corey Seager that's a rarity it's
like you know you talk about free agents
and the guys that were kind of signed
and traded and things like that this is
our one of our big acquisitions you know
we didn't have Corey all year and so to
get him back rich when you see him he
looks fantastic
means healthy he's moving well to see
them take the field to see him in the
batter's box obviously I get excited our
players get excited fans get excited so
we were considerably better when Corey
saw at the end early on I'm gonna you
know run them up they're three games and
then give them blow and get it back in
there and so we're gonna kind of man is
that early so then when we get in the
middle of summer we can kind of let it
go and the Dodgers done adding I mean
there's so many guys it's unbelievable
in this day and age the number of
talented players who are still unsigned
with opening day hitting I don't I don't
recall an instance like that are the
Dodgers done we're done we're done so
yeah there's a lot of times of players
out there obviously but I take that
in-house what we did in the winter where
we're at right now I love our guys I
love our depth and
Andrew Friedman our team president does
a very good job of kind of trying to put
together major league roster and prepare
for the unknown unforeseen injuries and
things like that so that's your question
yeah we're ready to go we're all set
how close were you with Bryce Harper I
know you met with him in Vegas with them
and you know I think that only Bryson
and Scott his agent could only tell you
how close was where I felt the thing
went well the BT you know with Bryce and
his his staff and his guys and his team
and his wife and our guys over there I'm
good I'm happy we've vetted the entire
process but ultimately he went where he
wanted to go so well we wish them well
that but again we're in a good place and
what we threw in a meeting like that
looks like for fans I mean you meet at
his house what are you over lunch I'm
like you spread what are you got and
unfortunately we flew private on our
owners jet go kind of backdoor hotel and
it's almost like Ocean's eleven you know
you kind of like figure like you got the
backdoor the Vegas casino it's not that
we're trying to take down a Kristine
understanding go there and then you go
up to the suite and you know you're on
two sides of a table and you're kind of
just chatting and you're talking about
the organization on the field part of it
the clubhouse at contract part and all
that kind of stuff and they're doing
listening they're talking expectations
and you kind of recess to regroup and
you kind of wait for the phone to ring
the next morning so for me it was a long
night
not a few hours sleep and had to get
ready to address a team the next morning
8 a.m. in Arizona so it was a good
experience for me so then the the
electricity goes out and the money's
looking gone is basically what you're
saying it just the ocean's phrase right
there that's amazing so then I guess the
phone didn't ring is that basically what
happened or you know the phone rang and
we got news that it wasn't gonna happen
so again we did a good job kind of going
through the process which a guy like
Bryce you gotta kind of you know see it
through and see see what see if there's
a chance in it um it didn't work out
like I said we wish you the best a
couple more minutes left here with Dave
Roberts with Puig on who is the most
likely player to lick a bat on your
roster right now Dave I would say
Enrique Hernandez I don't know if you
saw that exhibition game last night but
he's known once in a while rich to be a
little eccentric and he had some really
tight I painted on pants with the high
socks and so he's kind of quirky loves
the camera the social media thing so I
could see him being the guy licking a
bat all right how about snapping a bat
over a thigh like it's a toothpick who's
the most likely one good one
okay snapping a bat over the thigh I
would say probably Russell Hart I mean
he's uh okay he's like don't like a fire
hydrant he can snap and he's strong
enough to do it
so if Cody Bell to try to do it he might
snap his way so probably to it
I was gonna go Muncie I'm you know
Muncey's built like a fire hydrant
what one thing is but I still would go
Russell I mean that's a Canadian in him
I think the cave are flares
I got roughly and his Turner disease is
he cut that thing at all I mean why does
he show up to spring it seems so trimmed
it cut no trimmed it groomed it it's
still for me out of control but it suits
him tighten up the hair but he got on
this dairy-free thing so a lot of our
guys are on this Chase Utley's
dairy-free thing so JT
Cory all these guys look fantastic what
do you mean dairy-free
what are you talking they just kind of
don't do dairy anymore so whether it's
what you know the cheese whether it's
the cream and the coffee you know
whatever it is there's just no dairy and
they've kind of all leaned out it's a
different type thing I need to kind of
take heat I guess I guess look yeah you
eliminated the Brewers you got the
playoffs dairy-free last year right I
mean there you go I mean hey Dave always
appreciate our chats
have a great season or start of the
season we'll talk with you throughout
and always enjoy having you on the
program and I appreciate you taking time
before a big day all right we'll be in
touch take care you guys Dave Roberts
the Rich Eisen show weekdays
noon eastern on audience